there i mean
i feel like you literally
had everybody drink
whatever it was that you were serving up
when you walked out as the queen in the
crown i mean how does that feel to just
lasso everyone in
at word one
how did you approach that i'm just
curious because boy you beyond pulled it
off you got everyone on your side
everyone fell in love with you
boom
i didn't really think about it a lot i
had i had a four month old baby so i was
basically
trying to make the day go as fast as
humanly possible so i can get home
maybe that's the key
act fast go home and then
yeah i don't know i don't know so you're
saying your phone to them yeah
in a nutshell no i didn't i really put a
lot of thought into it paul
well i mean this show really really
works it's your chemistry so good the
subject matter's so enticing why do you
think people
just love scandals so much why do we
love it we're all trying to be such good
people but god we like the naughty stuff
we love the naughty stuff
i think that's why i think and it's a
really british thing i think as well
that everyone pretends to be behaving
themselves all the time and secretly
they're going home and getting up to all
sorts so i think that's um everybody
wants to know what everyone else is up
to it's why we like tv shows because it
gives you kind of a glimpse into other
people's lives and fortunately these two
characters
did all the things you sort of dream of
doing yourself had you watched a very
english scandal before what before
considering a very british scandal
i had just i had seen it just because
i'd seen it and i thought it was great i
think the tone of this is really
different because the subject matters it
is a bit darker
but i thought it was beautifully
uh done um but yeah we we had the luck
of having
a great a great writer sarah phelps who
who wrote it and and an amazing director
called ann sowitsky who
is uh well she's norwegian and and i
think that was really helpful having
somebody who wasn't encumbered and and
soaked in sort of british class system
to come in and and a woman
is the second her credit went by i was
like okay a woman directed this
interesting it's so
very
compelling beautifully shot
um in fact we have a clip um i'd love to
show you guys take a look i love it
i'm gonna sleep at club
and tomorrow morning we go back to the
inferrer first train i won't be
you'll do what i tell you to do when i
tell you to do it you must be confusing
me with one of your other wives
[Music]